okay let's now go to the sort of third
piece of this pie
which is uh trump is losing in the polls
and trump is getting more desperate and
what if trump doesn't accept the results
now let's actually explore what could
happen that would give trump a win
um and there's two sides to this there's
the election
tampering side and there's the policy
success
side now i'm going to be completely
transparent with you here
i think it is all but too late for trump
to do anything
on the policy side the three major
issues for voters as as a
per a new poll uh that we looked at
earlier this week the three major issues
facing voters right now are according to
voters
coronavirus number one the economy and
unemployment number two
which is very much related to
coronavirus and
george floyd police race relations
number three
those three are very bad for donald
trump economy is the best for trump
although he's now even to underwater on
economy
so what can trump actually do that is
just doing stuff politically to get
support
back another stimulus which is now in
the works certainly could help
um in terms of you know a vaccine
if a vaccine is finalized and goes
widespread before november
it will have nothing to do with trump i
mean literally nothing but trump will
try to take credit for it
and maybe some people would be convinced
by that the reality is the way things
are going
best case scenario is there's some early
doses for health care workers
in the fall and it may be after the
november election anyway
not totally clear if some super
effective treatment is found
trump could try to take credit for that
if through no fault of donald trump's
coronavirus improves and the economy
improves
trump can certainly try to take credit
he will claim credit and maybe it will
help him to
to some degree but i think you see the
theme which is
we're barely more than three months out
and the failures have compounded and
been so outrageous that
we essentially need miracles i say you
know if trump personally cures cancer
and you know cancer is so many different
things
if trump cures all cancers between now
and november
okay but on the issues there's really a
limited window for donald trump to be
able to do anything now
in terms of dirty tricks there's a lot
um what if william barr
announces an investigation maybe into
joe biden maybe into hunter biden in
october
might not even work at this point i
don't know that people will fall for it
people may see it as once again like the
hillary clinton thing all over again
but that might help trump there are at
this point people willing to essentially
crawl over
a broken glass to vote trump out not
everybody of course
but there is a high level of motivation
i don't even know if announcing an
investigation would work
could trump engineer some kind of
backroom peace deal with somebody and
tout it as a victory
the the grand deal with china a grand
deal with north korea that's believable
or
the taliban maybe i i just don't know
you know we we talk about
domestic politics is what works and
right now people are dealing with the
virus and the economic fallout
i just don't know that it would be
enough to change opinion so to be
perfectly honest and this is why it gets
very
as i said earlier this week a desperate
trump is a dangerous trump
trump's best path to victory right now
is suppressing the vote
and trying to rig it in his favor which
is why we have to be so vigilant on that
game
we have to stop the voter roll purges we
have to stop closures
of voting places we have to prevent
these paramilitaries from continuing to
be in cities
until november and being used to
intimidate voters out of voting
that's trump's best bet right now i
think he probably knows it
and that's why he's talking about vote
by mail and violence in cities because
he's essentially giving up on all these
other things that is why we have to
remain focused and prevent him from
using that
in order to win this election uh we have
a great bonus show for you today
remember that you can get the daily
audio podcast
every single day for free on
any of your favorite podcasting
platforms if you're an itunes gal
or a spotify guy or whatever it's
widely available make sure you're
getting the podcast daily
and we will see you on the bonus show